tout le monde dehors les on connaît la
rue des cures y passe pour aller à la
mairie
voilà la cathédrale pour venir au musée
bien sûr mais qui connaît pierre fougue
des cures à la fois archiconnu est
totalement méconnu
[Musique]
eh bien à partir de 1613 des cuirs a été
le maire d'orléans un des plus proches
amis d'henri iv vraiment un des
personnages très important pour
l'histoire de notre ville donc
naturellement il a eu droit à un très
beau cénotaphe très belle sépulture
composé d'une grande colonne sur
lesquels étaient posés ce buste
nous
il
[Musique]
évidemment ces bus l'immense qualité
réalisée par un sculpteur orléanais un
des meilleurs de son temps à vider au
musée des beaux-arts et paradoxalement
ceux des cures que tout le monde connais
de nom avait fini en réserve
pendant des décennies il a fallu les
travaux du musée des beaux-arts pour le
sortir et qu'il accueille aujourd'hui le
visiteur dans la salle consacrée à henri
iv
[Musique]